There is one more important point to be noted here.
This again is the illustration from incremental concept learning. When we
were talking about incremental concept learning, we talked about technique for
learning. We did not talk about how this concept were going to be used.
How about in correcting mistakes, we're talking about
how the agent actually uses the knowledge it learns. This point too,
is centered [INAUDIBLE] reason. The first reason is that knowledge based AI,
looks at reasoning. Looks at action, besides how knowledge is going to be used.
And then, determined what knowledge is to be learned. Assess the target for
learning, secondly you may recall this particular figure for
the target of architecture that we'd drawn earlier. You may see that reasoning,
learning and memory are closely connected, and all of that is occurring on
the surface of action selection. This figure suggests that we not only learn,
so that we can do action selection. But additionally, as we do action selection,
and we get feedback from the world, it informs the learning.
As this figure suggests, intelligent agents, cognitive systems, not only learn,
so that they can take actions on the world. But further, that the world gives
some feedback, and that feedback informs the learning. Once again, failure
a great opportunities for learning. One additional point to be made here,
learning by correcting mistakes, use learning as a problem-solving activity.
An agent meets failure, it needs to learn from the failure.
It converts this learning task into a problem-solving task. Let us first,
identify what knowledge are related to failure. Then, let us build and
explanation for this. Then we'll repair it. This learning is closely intertwined
with memory, reasoning, action, and feedback from the world. Notice also,
that there's reasoning, learning, and memory here. In the deliberation module
closely connected with the metacognition module. Here, the reasoning, memory,
and learning may be about action selection in the world.
But in a metacognition module may have its own reasoning, learning, and
memory capacities. And some of the learning in the metacognition is about fixing
the errors in the deliberative reasoning. So, metacognition is thinking about
thinking. The agent uses the knowledge, to think about the action selection, and
it conducted those actions in the world. Metacognition is thinking about
what went wrong in its original thinking. What was the knowledge error?
We'll return to metacognition in the lesson on metareasoning.